I have The High Ground word Smiths
because we're talking about the word
advantage in this video
Advantage a noun it means a better
position something that helps if we're
running a foot race and I get a three
minute Head Start Over You that's a
definite Advantage I got to start before
you did and indeed that's what the
derivation of this word gives us
avontage can literally be translated
from French as
beess so Avant means before in French
both before in time and before in space
so it can mean both earlier and in front
of a in English pronounced AG right this
AG is a noun forming suffix that also
comes from French it works like this you
pack stuff into a package you store
things in storage leaky things are prone
to leakage you get the picture so
thinking about Avant or advant right
with the D in there and H G as a noun
forming suffix what similar words can
you think of I'll give you 10 seconds
here we go music
[Music]
break here are three that I came up with
disadvantage right the opposite of
Advantage this is when something is
making things harder for you like your
opponent in a foot race getting a
three-minute head start for example uh
Advance is a verb that means to go
forward or to go onward or up Advantage
this noun is usually part of the phrase
Vantage Point means a good spot to view
things from the top of a hill is a great
vantage point from which to watch a
fireworks display for example all right
let's use advantage in a few
sentences Elias P beanpole the tallest
boy in sixth grade had a distinct
advantage
on the basketball court he was like 20t
tall he could dunk from half court that
was his advantage that's his Superior
position right but he did keep bonking
his head on the ceiling which I would
say is a distinct disadvantage to being
that tall listen just because my mom
runs a candy shop doesn't mean you could
take advantage of our friendship to take
advantage of an opportunity is to get
some benefit from it but not always in a
fair way to take advantage of a
friendship is to say something like hey
your mom has that candy shop how do you
feel about hooking up your friend David
with some free candy hm you do that
enough times and you're probably going
to exhaust your friend and your
friendship taking advantage doesn't have
to have a negative connotation or
feeling though you could take advantage
of a windy day and fly a kite or take
advantage of a rainy day and play a
board game that kind of
thing I hope you take advantage of these
videos dear wordsmiths and realize that
you can learn anything dve it out